ghostly figures of headless culture are
none bolita been bricked up in the walls
that appears and vanishes mysteriously a
screaming girl a feel of the room and
dragging foot sensing into halls the
scene of the ghostly visitations is the
rectory at Bali
there's no time 13 o clock what's up
it's us again in its episode 87 yeah
it's gonna be good show it's about the
barley regularly rectory yeah we wanted
to do another paranormal one this is
actually this is the request that at
least two times or anymore
actually I want to say that and I
probably mentioned this book before but
I have one of those old Reader's Digest
compilation book strange stories amazing
facts yeah well with the red cover and
the black is fine yeah
and um it had came out this late 60s or
early 70s something like that
and it had something about morally
rectory in it so I remember like seeing
the pictures of the house and the
pictures of like the weird writing on
the wall and stuff like that so it was
kind of cool when somebody requested
because I sort of forgotten all about it
even though I always found it a
fascinating story from back in the old
days I've been researching it for a week
now well yeah the first three or four
days three or four times just been kind
of looking at a different stuff about it
okay
and I actually wrote about there's a
little section about it in my book the
unseen hand also yeah so I know a little
bit about it there there's you know
there's another kind of [ __ ] about
it there's a movie and it came out last
year that's based on it and stuff like
that so you know we'll probably talk
about that a little bit well alright but
first let's do our kind of shout outs
type stuff okay the second volume of the
faceless tell in my true crime book I
just finished chapter 11 yeah so it only
has I think it has 18 it's gonna have 18
chapters so almost done so yeah so it's
more than half done at this point like I
gotta go in the studio and record it to
get on the audiobook
so we're probably looking at about a
month yeah something like that right
but you know the thing is the reason
this particular chapter took me such a
long time is because and I think and I
kind of said this in the introduction of
the book too
is that every time you go researching
unsolved murders I kept coming across
other ones right like that I didn't know
and like because I'd made I mean
obviously I'm not a dummy like I made
like a huge outline of all your cases
that I wanted to put in I'm like okay
that's it that's what I'm gonna put any
of each time you find one yeah it's like
each time you know if I'm talking about
like the Zodiac killer or something like
that then there's all these other
murders that are like tangential and
like related right or they think it
might've been the same guy or it might
have been this no wonder your constant
kind of getting pulled down another
direction you know should I take it this
way is that what's happening it's like
in one of the last chapters I was
writing I was writing about the murder
of sister Kathy sesnick which was we saw
the documentary kids called the keepers
on Netflix was about that okay and they
mentioned on that documentary that there
was another very similar murder that
happened like a month after hers of this
woman named Joyce Maliki but what they
didn't say you know and I got that one
in there but what they didn't say was
that there was two more like the next
year like one the following year in
their own a year after that and they
were also very similar and they didn't
even mention those in the documentary
and I only found that out by researching
the joyce molecular and researching that
then i was like what are these other two
in Baltimore that happened also so it's
like I keep coming up with new ones and
having a blank go Pat can stay out in
the book yeah what about that one about
the nun the dead nun was bizarre because
it seems to be that the priests were
pimping out the little girls they were
as she found out about it and they
killed her it might have been I'm not
real sure like I'm not saying that the
priests were pimping the girls out is a
cops and yeah local politicians and this
is what man
back in the 50s I think it was
1969 89 okay yeah I remember there was
something else yeah it was it's a crazy
story yeah you know in light of certain
things that are going down today rumors
going on today you're like damn how long
is stuff like to have been going on
always man it's always going on it's
just easy nowadays people are just more
I don't think it's more common now I
just think it's people think the
internet is exposing it well yeah it's
just it's more acceptable to talk about
it I think what happened back in like
the 50s or 60s people I'm sure we don't
talk about that right sort of thing you
know I mean priests pimping out the
schoolgirls to the damn cops yes yeah
there was some [ __ ] up [ __ ] go yeah
and this awesome you think that might
happen in some kind of weird semi
civilized place you know in another
country but you know the United States
all the time like I said I don't know
I'm not saying that particularly that
one priests rubber Maskull he's dead now
but um I'm not saying he wasn't a piece
of [ __ ] I don't know if he had her
murdered and the only reason that I say
that is because there because of the
other three murders the more I looked
into these other three murders that
happened over the course of this piece
is in the book yeah okay good yeah
sounds a good case the more I looked
into that those three murders were
awfully similar hers you know even down
to like weird little details so I kind
of think maybe it was a serial killer
everything but not just for that you
know Tamina no I don't know anyone know
more about the guy give book to yeah
besides this just one case and there's
gonna be dozens it does yeah there's a
[ __ ] yeah then I'm just like at and I'm
finding more all the time like three in
New Zealand that I wasn't even looking
for you unsolved murders Madison it's a
bottomless oh it is a bottomless pit is
a rabbit oh yes you find one and you
just keep finding other ones which is is
kind of depressing but you know people
are bad and it's shocking how many of
them don't get solved let's see what
else
our latest movie review was lone wolf
and cub oh yeah the six movie series
yeah so if you had this a little bit
different than the movies we usually
review so if you haven't checked that
out you should go check that out yeah
yeah it's weird
because like some of our subscribers
some of that we talk to you know Tamina
on other platforms sometime we'll talk
to like Val Trina will talk to her
personally
she's like God you guys know that one
she you know it was weird because you
know some some of our subscribers like
stuff like kung fu' movies but he loves
those as varied tastes and you never
know you never know what's gonna happen
you know with the 13 o'clock fans you
know they they like everything yeah well
in a way I think that's kind of what's
cool about well our show and we have
really varied interests also yeah like
yeah I'm super into horror and stuff
like that but I like a lot of other
stuff too so and I feel like a lot of
people have that and I so I think it's
good to get kind of a broad so yeah kind
of spread it out yeah I mean that being
said like our next probably five movie
reviews are gonna be horror movies
probably yeah yeah the next one
definitely is cuz it's already done but
yeah the next four the way I've written
don't tease I think someone's coming up
can we say do you want me to just say
what letter it starts with you go ahead
with it it starts with the P that's
right and ends with M yeah that's right
next movie review that's gonna come out
soon this is a teaser now phantasm yeah
[Laughter]
you got but yeah and then we've already
like pretty much planned what the next
four are gonna be yeah and they're
pretty much all or we got two videos a
lot logged up yeah there are actually
yeah there are they're all horror movies
right and yeah we're kind of gonna go
down kinda like an HP Lovecraft
direction for a little while - yeah
that's what I was thinking when I when I
was looking at the movies that we picked
we didn't really mean to it was just
kind of it just kind of backwards got
into some Lovecraft somewhat crafty look
Lovecraftian action yeah it's a little
by ways that yeah but yeah so that'll be
the next kind of stuff and also I'd like
to remind everybody that if you'd like
to support the show we have a patreon
page at patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast and we also
have if you don't like patriotic
sentiment l then you can go to our blog
which is 13 o'clock podcast up
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account also I want
to say hi to Trina because we were
talking her again over Facebook yeah on
Saturday night we were sitting around
watching movies getting drunk I was
loaded bet you as your letter - oh yeah
we drank a lot we didn't go out we just
stayed in yeah well because we have to
go out on Monday which is gonna be the
night before this show goes up one
mojito led to another the next thing you
know well you know now I accidentally I
accidentally called Bob Trina on face I
said [ __ ] it okay yeah and we were on
there for like three hours I know we
haven't talked in terms are like 2:00 in
the morning we're like talking about
movies and [ __ ] we were going to we're
watching I don't remember what movie
you're watching oh man
well we started off we watch Beverly
Hills Cop - yeah and then we watched oh
and then I put on - evil eyes but then I
was talking and I was earlie attention
all right I haven't seen that movie in a
really long time
Beverly Hills Cop is a good series I
forgot how good it was yeah it's it's as
good as I remember it actually held up
by East right now yeah I think it's
still funny well I still got movie three
to watch yeah blu-ray yeah we that's
supposed to be the worst one the third
one of anything is usually the worst one
I kind of think that I saw it when it
came out it came out a lot later than
the other ones like 10 years later and I
think I saw I didn't even know that was
the third one I think I got out of the
army and I saw that thing on playing I'm
a man matinee so much time in the
nineties in like the mid 90s I said I'm
gonna go watch that but it seemed kind
of out of place I was like you knows a
long time ago that yeah it's like why
would they bother with a bother next ten
years later yeah something like that was
weird
well I guess we'll see what I remember
thinking it was kind of mediocre yeah
but we'll see maybe it's better than I
remembered it sometimes maybe surprised
that it's either one way or the other
movies like a lot better than you
remember it
way worse than he remember but I wanna
see vampire in Brooklyn I haven't seen
that forever I liked it when it came out
I remember kind of like in that oh yeah
it was so much about it that was kind of
like kind of like a Murphy's version of
Blacula yeah and Blacula and screen
black of the screen were excellent
vampire movies they really liked it a
lot of job
yeah like know why those are actually
related movies and Anne Rice used those
there's a lot of inspiration for what a
vampire culture would be like yeah
pretty cool it's funny because I think
people think of them I guess this is the
titles they think of them as like in
this cheesiness organized lexi stations
but they weren't they're really not
they're actually pretty serious yeah
there was solid vampire movies and it's
actually like the guy that plays the guy
that plays Blacula is awesome yeah
that's Star Trek's it wasn't yeah he
played dr. daystrom
yeah you named the m5 yeah that's the m5
computer and yeah he's got like that
cool boys yeah right yeah yes yes oh
yeah I really like this movie since
scream Blacula screams had that whole
like voodoo thing his name wasn't
Blacula never Acula turned him into a
vampire halt then blackula yes that
wasn't his name that was his name right
what was it his name was mama wall name
on the wall there yeah young waldek he
was like a African Prince yeah it was
working with another guy to try to stop
the slave trade and it turned out
Dracula had instituted the slave trade
and we found that mama mama wall stopped
the slave trade Dracula killed him yeah
up inside of a damn correct
later on two gay guys a black one and a
white one is 70s bought that house and
found the crib let it out let them out
Dracula it drank some black dudes yeah
yeah or drink drink some gay dudes yeah
to reconstitute yourself we can see
every glass of selling that's right wait
out gay gay gay men have good taste you
know they saw that house oh we must have
this well yeah I remember that yeah
that's pretty cool
it was a pretty kick-ass house oh yeah
man I agree something comment
then another Skelton next to it nest
mama Wally's wife yeah
remember they see a girl live outside
the crib until she you know died of
starvation or something died of thirst
bastards
yeah that's a good flick but if you guys
ever want to see kind of cool Dracula
Dracula series or a vampire series see
ya black you'll and screen black of the
screen yeah probably gonna pretty cool
all right so now let's do the news story
and I like when this happens because I
can do some self pimping sometimes a
woman's gotta say well it just and I
swear to God I did not do this on
purpose but you know whenever we're
doing like a paranormal topic I always
try to find like a paranormal tech news
story so I'm searching through you know
like the Google search for paranormal
news or whatever and lo and behold they
are on the den of geek blog which I
usually read for they're Walking Dead
reviews and whatnot they had an
interview with a legendary Keith Lander
Keith Linder and as it turned out and it
was just dated like a couple of days ago
now it turns out that there is a new
book coming out about the Keith Linder
quote-unquote demons in Seattle
haunting now for those of you who are
new to the show Jennie wrote a book
about the Keith lender case she has the
first person to ever write about this
yeah I read it in late 2016
right a guy that we work with a British
parapsychologist that we work with Steve
Mehra went from the UK to key cleaners
house here in the United States to
investigate yes yet 'el and found a
bunch of a VPS and EVPs and brought back
some data and gave his opinion of what
was going on within his place of course
we've yet to review this new book we
don't know anything about it yeah it
just came out on April 15 Sunday which
was two days before this show goes up so
we don't know if the case is involved or
yet the book says it's called the
Buffalo Hell House
okay poltergeist of Washington state
that's what the book is called I'm not
as a sensational title I'm gonna go
ahead and reserve judgment yeah yeah
mine is called house afire winds that's
right
now that what I did was because um I
based it entirely off Steve Mehra's
recollections and his Case Files and all
of the data that he collected while he
was there so mine kind of goes into the
claims that Keith Linder made about what
he saw prior to Steve Berra getting
there because he lived because he had
lived there for like four years before
Steve Mary came and there had been other
ghost hunting teams in and out of there
including Zach and they had been there
also demon just constantly but yeah so
so mine kind of focuses more on you know
even though it goes into stuff that
happened before Steve Mara got there
it's kind of mostly from Steve's point
of view you know talks about what he saw
and Don Phillips roses they both went
there he's a [ __ ] Oreo techni special
audio technician yes and he's sort of
like I don't want to use the word medium
but he's kind of like one of they call
him in a catalyst yeah that he's
supposed to be like he's around and
paramount more paranormal yeah and it
has this kind of personality that you
get him into a certain place to where
their paranormal stuff has a tendency to
happen
his personality can kind of accentuate
it and kick it up a notch
yeah which you know that kind of goes
along with some of the stuff that I've
observed so you know I mean I can't you
know discount that yeah it's a
possibility right I think maybe there
are certain people that have a certain
kind of energy or some kind of character
some kind of quality about them to where
[ __ ] goes down if they're around yeah or
it's more likely to go down yeah and I
think that's what is it sighs - yes
so the thing is I don't know
this new book is gonna be any good now
it should be noted that Keith lender
does not live in this house anymore he
moved away from it in 2016 I believe
continues to be in his own case well I
guess or either that or someone
approached him to do memoize to do a
memoir type of thing he actually did
read my book before I publish it and he
just made a couple of minor correction
right you liked your book yeah he did so
you know so it's not a case of what he
just thought I did a hack job and he
brought somebody else right it was kind
of a no probably you know what talking
to him from what I remember he said he
also one day wanted to do his because
there's a lot of stuff that he had seen
like I said - mostly from Steve Meyers
perspective because you know he co-wrote
the book with band it was all from his
so it's gonna be kind of like additional
testimony you're interested in the case
or if you're interested in the first
book that Jenny wrote you probably would
want by that book also probably
interesting read yeah and I I'm actually
planning on reading it because I find
that a really interesting case okay I
mean I don't know how how accurate a lot
of the stuff that he said that he saw
before anybody got there was but I mean
we know Steve Merrill long enough that
if he you know if he goes to a house and
he says he saw X Y & Z she heard X Y & Z
then I'm Way more inclined to believe
that he's oh he's a reliable observer
yeah and he does do a good job of
documenting yeah what he observes and
what other people observe and he he's
pretty good at coming up with theory
with theories to explain yes possibly
what could be going on and I and what I
always liked about Steve was so classy
about Steve is that he's kind of
non-committal committal yeah about you
know he says this is what we believed
happened
this is what we saw this is what that
person told me that they saw and he just
kind of leaves it up to the tip which is
a lot of the same way that I approach
things as well it's just kind of like
I'm willing to give you the benefit of
the doubt provided you know what you say
isn't to grow saying well what else you
gonna do if you don't see it you can all
right leave that's all I want somebody
that's all you can do and that's what I
tried to do with this book it's like I
said I'll believe Steve when he said I
saw this XYZ he let me listen to the
EVPs yeah and then in fact I've links to
the CV piece and a VPS are right there
on your they're in the audio no they
know about the e-book there's a book and
you can hear them I've heard I got the
same thing that they're pretty spooky
it's weird they are very sweet and a lot
of them are very clear yes some of the
clearest EVPs I've ever heard yeah this
is intelligent they seem to be answering
question it's the weirdest thing because
you have to you have two people on
screen talking to one another and it
seems normal and to go back and listen
to it again
and in between all they're talking you
hear like a word
yeah it's spoken out loud yeah like
someone else is there but they're not
and right and you know it's there's
nobody else in the room it's almost
what's weird is that sometimes they
sound like words or a human voice sound
like that but they don't sound there's
almost something kind of almost like
it's an audio phenomena yes they did
hear it at the time yeah most of the
things in the night this is almost like
an acoustical phenomenon yes
sounded like a damn sentence or right
yeah what's weird
because he said they didn't they did
hear a couple of EVPs as in Dave Berg
voices like actually I was a thin air
right but most of the EVPs and they
ended up getting some ridiculous number
like of 400 500 EVP is something like
that and he's like most of them we
weren't aware of until we got back to
England and we're listening back to all
the tapes because they were there they
actually were there Steve Mara Don
Phillips were at Keith's lender's house
when Keith lenders still lived there on
two occasions the first occasion they
were there for six days and the second
occasions everything for eight days and
they were living in the vows so they had
cameras set up everywhere they had audio
running constantly and so they got a lot
of evidence and what's what's cool about
the ones that does Steve got is that you
know when you hear EVPs yeah on
television they have to turn the volume
way up they have to tell you what was
that
yeah and then you hear it you go yeah it
does kind of sound like that these don't
really sound like that they actually
sound like a human voice but it sounds
like I mean you don't have to have
anybody don't you what it says yeah and
it sounds like just somebody whispered
whispered something yeah yeah outdoor
and there's so many of them you can't
really characterize them all yeah one of
the creepiest ones was that it was the
one where that and they actually got it
on video they were videotaping just then
sending up some equipment so they
weren't even like really recording they
were just setting some [ __ ] up and
recording and the they have a little
camera thing and they were kind of doing
or whatever and then this voice very
clearly says yeah yes yeah just like it
was a person like yeah the microphone
yeah but you know that it wasn't it's
not it's not that it's not that clear
and it's clear but you know that there
wasn't somebody off camera just
whispering into the microphone and then
trying to pass it off as a fake EVP yeah
it sounds unusual it doesn't it's been
in a way that's kind of hard to describe
yeah you just have to hear yourself yeah
but yeah if you're really interested in
the Keith lender case I don't want to
like do a whole show about it because I
wrote a whole book about it and smell
right and actually I would I did a radio
interview for my side of the universe I
think the radio is could the the show is
called in Utah and I talked quite a bit
about the Keith lender case like the
only about a quarter of the yeah of the
segment before I remember that before
before I forget yes Keith Linder got a
bum rap on Ghost Adventures
yes if you will that was why he called
seamless that's why I meant to Steve if
you look watch the Ghost Adventures show
they butcher that investigation she did
and the investigation contradicts itself
yeah saying there's nothing paranormal
here but Keith's Linder's girlfriend's
behind it because she used black magic
if she used black magic that's [ __ ]
paranormal yeah how can you say that
thing about ghosts and there was no
black magic they just made that [ __ ] up
and the thing about and and this is why
maybe I'm kind of like don't have as
much patience with [ __ ] Ghost
Adventures because I know from talking
to Keith lender from talking to Steve
Mara and stuff
like that that what shows up on Ghost
Adventures when they come to your house
and do a quote-unquote investigation
this kind of messed up Keith's life
because he him and his girlfriend tina
moved into this house they held as
paranormal [ __ ] going on they finally
called they called some different
psychics and [ __ ] like that but then
they finally got Ghost Adventures in
there Ghost Adventures like you said
basically did a hatchet job and when the
show came out basically saying oh we
didn't find any paranormal stuff oh
maybe they're faking oh but maybe she's
had is doing black magic and causing bad
mojo or whoa that's true then they need
to get back in there investigate some
way black magic that show aired yeah she
started getting hate mail yeah she left
us and she ended up living him couldn't
take it anymore
yeah it was it's pretty much just ruined
her but it looked like to look like to
me that Ghost Adventures did not want to
put out a whole episode of positive
cases so they said you know some of our
cases that we're gonna cover we're gonna
say they're hoaxes yeah all right so
look more legit whatever and I mean I
will say that some of the claims that
Keith Linder was making about some of
the stuff that happened before Ghost
Adventures got there before Steve Mehra
got there were pretty outlandish not in
the sense that I'm saying he was making
it up but they're crazy I mean crazy
[ __ ] happened yeah was like all the
writing about hearing on the wall and
like his whole office being trashed you
know there was like all kind of fires
and [ __ ] like that so you know he was
making some some people kind of said
extraordinary claims some people were
saying well did is writing a hoax in
order did he hopes that to get a
paranormal investigator and dude in
there because no one else was helping it
before and then you know did he was that
the bait to get somebody in to
investigate it nobody knows yeah only
people that actually were there but like
I said you know Steve marrow was there
doc Phillips was there they got a lot of
evidence that nothing like super
spectacular yeah but they got stuff to
that stuff
happened and they saw it and they they
got it all down as evidence so and it's
stuff like this is just par for the
course that's the name of the paranormal
game you're dealing with a lot of
what-ifs and maybe sometimes that just
goes along with the course yeah and
that's just how it is not no case is
perfect including the best one which is
Enfield poltergeist yeah you know that
case was not perfect but that case was
real that did happen just because a
couple things were faked
yeah as the girls were [ __ ] around
doesn't mean that you you have to you
well in that night you should throw that
entire case out when you had cops this
chairs moved and you saw newspaper
reporters saw Lego bricks jump up out of
the corner and hit people in the head
yeah that is suppose yes and it happens
a lot you know particularly where
there's young kids involved right
there's gonna be especially if the if
the meteor somebody like that comes to
see it and it's not doing any other
Justin yeah the kids don't want to look
stupid or they were on attention or
something so yeah they'll fake some
things but that don't mean everything's
fake this is our leads yeah all right so
now that we're almost half okay we got
to do the record all right so now we're
getting into the case of a Borle rectory
yeah otherwise known as the most haunted
house in England not anymore because
it's not there anymore all right
there is really there's such a mystique
about this place
and like I said I remember reading about
it when I was a kid and strange stories
amazing facts and always just finding it
this really creepy story so let's kind
of talk about a little bit of the
history of Morley rectory now it was
actually built in 1862 it's um it's in
this little town it's like a little
parish called barley it's like right on
the border of the Essex and Suffolk
counties and it was built on the site of
a previous rectory which I believe had
burned down but it was built for the
Reverend Henry Dawson Ellis bull and his
wife and 14 children
so they had this rectory built for them
to move into it now sources very some
sources say that the locals in the area
were already reporting minor paranormal
activity even before the rectory was
built you know what I mean and even
after the rector's put up like he before
the family moved in you know he said oh
we kept hearing footsteps and there was
all this other kind of stuff so there
was apparently some minor paranormal
activity before that was even there and
you know step about maybe the land is
haunted or whatever yeah now there was
evidently a story about the area that at
some point probably in around the 13th
century that this portion of land had
been there was been a monastery on it
and I don't know what this is the case
or not but apparently in this monastery
there was a monk and he fell in love
with a nun or a novice and evidently
they tried to run away or a lobe or
something like that and they got caught
and because it was the Middle Ages in
the church - absolutely did not [ __ ]
around they took the monk and hanged him
then they took the nun and they bricked
her up alive she died in there so now I
don't know if that really happened but
that's the legend that's that's the
legend well first off you know that
breaking up a woman alive also a nun
that goes back to the Roman time yeah
where they were a wall of a vestal
virgin yeah if she broke her vow so I'm
starting to think that might be a little
bit legend that might be yeah and if she
be notice to that that same story of
breaking up the nun alive and that story
and said like that has occurred in a
couple of fictional yeah I know novels
they got that from the ancient Romans
right like I think it was in a poem by
Sir Walter stye and there was like a
another novel that had come out a few
years before that had a similar story so
that might have been where that came
home so nothing much happened at first
other than like kind of footsteps sounds
of doors closing stuff like that then
comes 1900 now three or four of Bulls
daughters evidently we're coming home
from a party or some
like that they're going into the rectory
and they see what appears to be a woman
in a nun's habit standing out in the
yard and she kind of looks like she has
her head down no at first they say they
thought this was a person and they
thought something was the matter with
her so they went over to talk to her and
she apparently faded away so that was
kind of one of the main and really the
whole time the Bulls were there and then
there was another family there afterward
it's mostly apparition stuff so the most
commonly reported apparitions a nun
walking around with her head down a
phantom carriage with two headless
coachman okay which you know that seems
pretty alright spectacular so what that
was seen several times but then there
was also kind of some sources say
there's like a little girl and whites
like sometimes she would you could see
her face against the window or something
she could hear her screaming
particularly in one of the bedrooms so
it's mostly that kind of thing
while the Bulls are there now evidently
the Reverend bull had taken to you know
writing down all of these things that
happened there and he reportedly thought
that it was kind of amusing like he had
built this little summer house or like a
little gazebo type of thing out in the
yard so he could go out after dinner and
have a cigar and like watch for the
ghosts maybe I'll see the nun today you
know what I mean so they I think he
thought it was kind of neat that's not
all that really yeah look at me I
thought the poltergeist is neat even
though it scared the [ __ ] out of me well
that's what I mean after I mean yeah
it's scary like sure it'd be scary if
you lived in a house where there's like
a phantom carriage with like headless
dudes like right all the time but you'd
run and you'd immediately want to go
back
yeah you would because it's like this
it's probably not gonna hurt you I don't
think you know so that was kind of the
main things were you know just minor
poltergeist activity weird noises stuff
like that in some apparitions and after
the Reverend bull died one of his sons
took over and lived in there for a while
and had a similar types of you know
experiences and then his son eventually
died in 1928 and then after that there
was there was a few months gap and then
there was another rector moved in
reverend guy eric smith and his wife and
then they moved into the house now they
did not report any paranormal activity
until the story goes mrs. smith was
cleaning out some type of cabinet or you
know cupboard or whatever and she finds
like a package that's wrapped in brown
paper and the bat like tucked into the
back and she takes it out and unwraps it
and there's a spell in there okay
apparently everywhere says a young
woman's skull I'm not sure how that was
verified or where they took it or
anything like that but it always says
it's a young woman's skull so after that
was found then it seems like the
Paranormal Activity started up again
footsteps hearing knocking on the walls
the servant bells would ring even though
they weren't connected to anything
lights would come on in the windows all
that kind of stuff mrs. Smith also said
that she saw the horse-drawn carriage
after that happened she ended up calling
the newspaper The Daily Mirror and the
SPR Society for psychical research and
asked them to come out and investigate
The Daily Mirror ended up doing like a
bunch of articles about it and they also
were the one that's sent the infamous
Harry price the parapsychologists both
paranormal researcher and he was also a
magician sent him out to investigate it
too and it's probably through Harry
prices writings that Boily rectory
became as famous as it did because he
ended up writing I believe two books on
the subject he was the one that started
calling it the most haunted house in
England
okay this is basically the source of the
stories is this yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's why I'm very sure yeah he's good
the primary source and he was there for
a long time he came along in the 1929 I
believe and did some investigations at
the place and we'll kind of get into
that I guess you know we're kind of at
the halfway point now so yeah I think
we'll get into the rest of the story
like after the break
sounds good so we're gonna take a break
right now and we'll be back in just a
couple minutes
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and declared at the end
of the day that this house is very much
haunted and will continue to be honored
there a long time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back talking about Borle
rectory England's most haunted house
yeah we're just now getting down to the
nitty-gritty on this case - yeah
so in 1929 Harry price arrives all right
now Harry price is kind of a
controversial figure I guess you could
say in sort of early paranormal research
should be noted that he's kind of the
first guy to come up with this sort of
ghost hunting kit okay he did approach
things from a very scientific standpoint
but as I said he was also a magician and
a conjurer which in a way I think is
good because she can do some Houdini
[ __ ] so you can spot when people are
faking right however many of his
detractors have said that he probably
faked it fakes things himself just you
know for better publicity and whatnot I
don't know how true that is
I mean obviously he's something to
consider
yeah now when he arrives to Morley
rectory and started his first
investigation the interestingly even
though prior to this most of the
manifestations had been apparitions
mostly but when he arrived stuff started
going in a more poltergeist II type
direction okay there were you know
stones and bottles started flying around
okay
rapping on the walls you know in a
communicating type of fashion a and now
the stones and the bottles yeah from
coming from outside the rectory coming
in or their stones inside the rectory
flying around
I think stones and bottles inside the
rectory fly around so I don't know if
anyone actually really saw where they
came from oka it's just that you kind of
just saw them in flight suddenly okay
the stones coming from the outside in is
actually a pretty common poltergeist it
is very common yeah right yeah and I
went into that in the MT and there's
like I had a whole section on stone
throwing Poulter yeah and it was a
factor in a lot of cases - that weren't
even in that section okay but yeah it is
a pretty common thing okay now mrs.
Smith the reverend's wife who was living
there at the time she has gone on record
as stating that she even though she had
seen apparitions and stuff like that she
thought that all the new poltergeist II
[ __ ] that was going on was Harry price
doing it thank you she thought he was
right did she have any evidence see I
don't know but it was her beliefs now
she did believe that the [ __ ] was
haunted she said I've seen the Phantom
carriage or all that said I think she'd
even seen the not God he was Adam but
she thought he was adding to it I don't
know if that's the case but that was her
opinion good I'd like to have more
detail about what it is I think she saw
yeah well yeah there's a little bit more
about that later on like not so much
about her but about other people so now
the Smith family were really only there
I think they were only there for two
years and then they got the [ __ ] out now
after they left because I guess I don't
know I guess they just didn't take it it
was too much going on so after the
Smiths left it actually took quite a
while for the village of Morley to find
another rector to take over the posts
just because the house hadn't started to
gain such a bad reputation of being
haunted but finally in 1930 they got the
Reverend Lionel Algernon Forrester okay
I can't have a name worse than that if
that is the British no it could only be
more British that the last name was
hyphenated okay should have had the
first name Nigel Lionel Algernon sir
otherwise known as Nigel our British
listeners if you ever had a kid named
Nigel and you send it to school the
United States you come here poor kid I
can't even think of anything without
thinking of that XTC song making plans
for Nigel yeah Nigel I love that song
it's not a bad name it's just it's just
you know I think of that where I think
of spinal tap yes that's what that's
what I think of it yeah I can't help
that okay so the very British the very
Reverend Lyell al-jalil moister he moves
into the rectory with his much younger
wife Marianne and their adopted teenage
daughter Adelaide now it seems that as
soon as the boy sirs moved in that the
paranormal activity ramped up a lot they
also heard the footsteps they also heard
the servant bell ringing even though it
was disconnected they also said they
heard weird music like the game tell
where it was coming from and they also
reported poltergeist activity stones and
bottles flying around windows breaking
objects disappearing and reappearing in
other places that's classic oh yeah why
I'm turning into ink which I thought was
very odd why I'm turning into yeah never
heard of that yeah I mean it's possible
that a culture come up in in other
poltergeist but it's not common having
seen poltergeist phenomenon myself most
likely when wine turns into ink what it
is the poltergeist takes the wine away
then put since then yeah there instead
so tea shorts on yeah although is that
you is that any less crazy like when I'm
trans meeting wine into ink then just
take it all the white out immediately in
putting ink in there that's why that's
how it would do it yeah yeah well it
does seem easier to do oh yeah it's
gonna it's gonna cheat that's what's
going to alter guys are big dirty
cheaters as the demonstration designed
to impress you and to put you into
wonderment of how that happened because
whenever the one that you know that we
encountered in our family that's what it
when it did something it was it was done
as a demonstration you were supposed to
see it and you're supposed to go how the
hell gonna do that and that well and
most parapsychologist would argue that
the whole reason that a poltergeist and
I don't like I don't really want to talk
about it as though it's a separate
entity because I don't think it is but
the reason that a poltergeist does what
it does is to get a reaction of people
which further feels yeah proto helps
fuel you know yeah it like grants the
energy up and ramps up the emotions I
think what it does is it ramped
something the confidence of the
poltergeist agent who's unconsciously
producing it yeah yeah that's just
that's what it's doing so and even kind
of started doing violent [ __ ] like
evidently Mary and the why
she got thrown out of bed a few times
the daughter was like locked in a room
from the outside but no one had done it
like there was no key to that nor it
couldn't be locked or whatever so it
started to do more violent [ __ ] oh and
also Marian got she got thrown in a bed
a few times but also she had like a
mattress like slammed on top of her like
it was trying to suffocate her like that
so she said now the weird thing about
though and this was one of the things
that creeped me out about this case when
I saw the pictures of it from that long
ago Reader's Digest but I call it long
ago it's sitting right looking right at
it it's right there unless it's right
there myself I still have it all right
but apparently the poltergeist started
writing on the walls like writing
started appear on the walls and there
are pictures of it and I'll put pictures
of it in the YouTube video but they were
pictures up in the book and I think
that's what creeped me out the most most
of it you couldn't read it just kind of
looked like loosen like scribble yeah
but some of it looked like it was asking
Mary Ann for help like it would say
something like Mary Ann please get help
or Meriton ly please for hopes and
prayers or you know things like would
people see the writing appear see that
I'm not sure about because if you see
the pictures it looks as though because
there's little block letters which I
assume is Mary Ann's handwriting so she
would ask it a question like she would
write on the wall like I don't
understand what you sleepy was it was
messy and she's gonna read it and she
would put out understand please tell me
more and then there'd be more chicken
scratch underneath and sometimes it
would be legible most of the time night
and would happen when they weren't
looking at it they would buy one badness
like I said I've just seen the pictures
of it I don't know that's not happened
in my case yeah in Mammoth Mountain
right you know I mean we you shut the
shades turn the lights off go downstairs
get in the car you look up at the main
window the lights are back on the shades
are open yeah he's the hall man you're
not like that
it's a blue haze and they're you okay
let's get out of here go get some pizza
you come back you go up there lights are
still on shades still open you look and
there's it's written on the winch on the
window and wax from a twist I go so we
didn't see it
B you didn't see it write it but there
was no
nobody there it was already there now
Louis says she saw it writing it but me
and red go now there's no way you could
have seen that because we didn't well
I've seen pictures of the outside of the
place I don't think he would have been
able to see no she miss Russian wanna
miss remembered it you know she's in her
70s and she's miss remembering it she
didn't smooth it and see it written we
found it and it was all great decided
already Britney and never any better
than that yeah but yeah so that seemed
like the case here there was like
writing evidently appearing on the walls
I don't think they were looking at it
and then the road or did you stir around
and then it was there I don't know so
Reverend boy stur actually tried to do a
couple exorcisms on the house neither of
which worked reportedly during one of
the exorcisms stone came flying out of
nowhere and whacked him on the shoulder
yeah yeah honestly not that you know
when that was witnessed I don't know
though okay yeah nobody knows if that
was that it these a lot of the stories
about morally rectory yeah are like
repeated from other sources so a lot of
them just say hey you got hit by a stone
about the size of she don't know how
many nice yeah I don't know if other
people saw that happen or if he just
said it happen or just the family said
it happened I don't know there's the
problem like I said I said yeah you run
into this a lot when you're bad and
that's why when I was writing on scene
and I was having such a hard time it's
just because so many things get repeated
and you don't really know where unless
you could find the original sources
which is sometimes hard right you don't
really know like okay did they really
see this or are they just repeating or
what they heard or something like that
and and this case is really a lot there
is a lot of that going on you know you
can't throw the case out no but you just
have to be aware that the witness
testimony in most of these cases is very
cloudy yeah I don't know who saw this or
where you don't I mean like yes this man
was hit with a stone well wait a minute
who's who witnessed this who's telling
you this the guy who got hit with a
stone yeah was he the only one in the
room and he came down did he actually
say this we don't know yeah yeah
I kind of feel like that might have just
been something he reported her something
the family reported because now Harry
price came back again he had been there
with the Smiths with the Smith family
and now he came back to investigate
again when the boy stirs were there and
she thought that Marianne was acting as
essentially the poltergeist focus okay
he wasn't sure if she was conscious of
it or if it was unconscious but he
definitely thought that it was probably
her and he theorized that that's
probably why the parent wants to be
ramped up after the boys moved in if we
haven't had been before now just in case
we have new listeners that haven't been
following this show for long turkey you
explained to them what a poltergeist
focus is what is well it's basically
just the person around whom poltergeist
activity is happening I mean we think
that the person that's the focus is
unconsciously causing the disturbances
through some type of unconscious
psychokinesis yeah usually it's called
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis yeah
which is an unconscious psychokinesis
that happens at random so I think he
thought that was the case here but then
the weird thing was that Marianne said
that even though she thought that some
of the phenomena was genuine she thought
also that Harry price and maybe her
husband were doing some of the [ __ ]
themselves
although it must be said I don't know
how trustworthy his family are really
good because it turned out that later on
Marianne admitted that she faked a bunch
of [ __ ] for pranks also she was sleeping
with someone of the guy that was lodging
in the house like what their tenants and
she later admitted that she kind of been
using the paranormal activity whether it
was real or not to kind of allay you
know to kind of get attention off of her
and write a little shenanigans
distraction pretty much dick yeah yeah
now here's the funny thing I was
watching a British documentary about
this
and this is the only place that I ever
saw this mentioned and so I don't know
if this is Church to take this with a
grain of salt but apparently this whole
hoister marriage the Reverend and her
was a little weird because I mean like I
said he was much older than her he knows
about her father's age right and so she
was banging this lodger yeah now later
on the reverend her husband gave her and
the lodger money to open a flower shop
in town and they both ran the flower
shop and lived in town together during
the week okay and then she would come
back to the rectory on the weekends and
like be with her husband and Titus you
know yeah which I thought was kind of
like psycho free love types that yeah so
I guess lady was just kind of like
whatever and they had an adopted teenage
daughter - yes was weird okay maybe he's
an older guy he's collecting young women
yeah yeah I don't know it's just it
seems like like I said I don't know if
that's true because I saw that like on
one dime we don't know that well we
don't know yeah and they're you know
they've passed away after it so the
foster family ended up being there until
1935 and then Lionel voicer kind of got
sick and he couldn't do the rectory
thing anymore the rector thing anymore
so they moved out now after that
happened Harry price took the
interesting tack of renting Borle
rectory for an entire year and he ran an
ad in the paper and he said he was
looking for people of leisure and
intelligence you had to go in there
stated go in there and say he was gonna
die
I know well this was this was this is
like 37 is it yes so we have to get a
time machine here back okay that's it so
yeah he so he actually ended up getting
a whole bunch of it was mostly students
I think he ended up getting about 48 of
them they weren't there 24/7 but he had
them there in rotating shifts and like I
said he's in a way he's sort of like the
Godfather of like parallel researching
or whatever just because he came up with
the ghost hunting kid he had like all
these taped instructions to tell them
like how to investigate the house and
how they needed
document everything and stuff like that
so they were there for a year and
apparently some crazy [ __ ] happened they
documented but nothing like super super
crazy mostly just noises you know
footsteps lights that type of thing
nothing super venture in the 30 singing
theme didn't even have portable audio
recording equipment so now be hard to
collect evidence in the 30s and then
that decent cap they had okay cameras
yeah so later on price and some of these
students they decide to do some seances
on the property now one of the seances
they get allegedly
the spirit of a nun it it should be
noted significantly this nun is not the
nun that was bricked up right this nun I
don't think there wasn't done mercy I
don't think there was either I think
that was just a story though and so can
they just like kind of where mantis eyes
denim yeah kind of just was a local
legend type of thing so I don't think
that hold not bricked up in the wall now
that's a Roman they're talking about
Vestal Virgins yeah right but he's so he
apparently contacts a woman who was a
nun her name was Marie layer and she was
French and apparently she had fallen in
love with someone from the Walda Grove
family now the Walter Byrd family were
real they they did live in that area
Borle and actually in Morley Church
which is right across from which is
still there and it's across from the
site where Burleigh rectory was it was
built in the 12th century and there's
actually the the Waldegrave family tomb
is still in there like you know you can
still see it so evidently she was in
love with one of them and then somebody
ended up murdering her and either
burying her on the grounds or throwing
her down a well or something like that
so now they're thinking well there
wasn't so much this whole you know none
bricked up in the wall but maybe this is
the nun that's the ghost that all these
people have been seeing now weirdly he
also said that during another one of
these séances they contacted this male
spirit with the very weird name I think
it was soon
summer is or something like that yeah I
was like okay already now he says at
this particular you know they're with
their little Ouija board or whatever he
says I'm gonna burn this [ __ ] down
tonight cool right now did the house
burn down that night it did not okay
however 11 months later by then you know
Harry prices lease was up and they had
moved down and the students and this
other guy had moved in named Captain WH
Gregson now he was moving in and he was
putting his books in the library or
whatever and he either accidentally
knocked over an oil lamp or the oil lamp
fell over like in a ghostly fashion I'm
not really sure her so much sources have
different things and the [ __ ] didn't
burned completely down but it was gutted
to a point where they couldn't see this
damn you know so so old sue next summer
is through the Ouija board he's like I
wanna burn is it I'll burn it down
tonight but what I've heard out about a
year from now okay but it did and it
didn't burn down just burn it it burned
I'll just burn the [ __ ] out I just
burned the [ __ ] out of it so that nobody
could live in it and that was in 1939
that fire and there are rumors that
local said that after the place was
gutted they still saw the nun like in
the windows every now and then show like
that now in 1944 they raised it and
there's nothing there now now the church
is still there there's actually a really
interesting I was watching that
earlier today I think the guy's name is
Christopher or Halton I want to say or
something from like that and he had done
he's like he thought thought this was
really weird because Gourley Church is
still there like I said it's from the
12th century he's like and a lot of
paranormal activity has been reported in
here too but Harry price never like
walked across the lawn from to
investigate over there which he thought
was very odd and evidently there's been
a lot of and they actually interviewed
some people that had
in there since you know recently and
reported hearing footsteps
there was even in 1975 the BBC did serve
a little documentary and they had an
investigation in the church you know
obviously because the rector wasn't
there by that time and they recorded
some pretty creepy son of a recorded
footsteps when there's no one in there
they recorded what was clearly the sound
of like a door slamming they recorded
what sounded like a person sighing like
it was just like like that it was pretty
much just like that except the man so
there's no there was a lot of stuff
going on in there and that's weird
because it doesn't really get mentioned
right
they even had this one guy who was
talking about how back in the 80s him
and his friend Ian had actually they
were going to go camp on the site of
Morley rectory just for shits and
giggles they set up a tent overnight and
they're sleeping in there and they said
that they started hearing people talking
and then they got out of the terrace and
then they started hearing like someone's
hands on the outside of the canvas yeah
and then they got out of the tent and
there was nobody there and then they got
freaked out and started running away and
Ian apparently turned around and saw two
figures like two in white yeah he's like
it was a man and a woman and they were
just standing there like by the side by
the church and they were just like
looking at him and he said freaked him
the [ __ ] out and his friend that was
telling the story said I had never heard
a man scream well what did they do did
they approach the the people in white no
they ran the [ __ ] away that might has
been real people though it might have
been but he said he said it really did
not look like real people he said they
were just standing there and they just
had like these weird one expressions on
their faces and they said when they went
back the next day to pick up their tent
he said the tent had all this really
weird like all these weird stains on it
he said he said I'm not gonna be cliche
and say it was blood and stuff like that
but he's like there were reddish stains
on the tent that weren't there before
he's like I don't know what that was
least they weren't whitish State
okay yeah yeah so you know after the
place was torn down and because Harry
price wrote two books about it and there
were all these stories circulating about
it so like I said it kind of became
really probably one of the best-known
haunted houses in England for sure yeah
just a really popular ghost story
now the Society for psychical research
okay yeah these guys they decided I mean
obviously by the time they decided to
kind of look more into this the rectory
was gone these are you know it's a cool
outfit but they failed to investigate
one of the best paranormal cases of all
times which was infill build case they
didn't even spend the time out uh yes
something may be going on over there but
then you know who gives a [ __ ] no I'm
just yeah you know the guys involved in
that case you know we don't really you
know believe them but yeah [ __ ] it yeah
okay their attitude to head towards that
they wouldn't send anybody down there to
spend a couple of days at that house
which makes me always lead always makes
me believe that they already had their
minds made up they may have and they may
have in this particular case as I said
when they became interested I think they
became interested in it because of the
kind of public fascination with it and
that came in the wake of Harry prices
books about it and after it was torn
down they sort of went through all of
Harry prices data and like all the stuff
that he had that he had come up with
while he was there and that most of them
came to the conclusion that they thought
pretty much all of the poltergeist
activity type activity was just
naturalistic explanations
you know just weird acoustics spra the
ESPE are saying this you know that it
was just not who rats in the walls
things like that yeah and they said some
of the other [ __ ] like the poltergeist
[ __ ] they straight up pretty much said
that they thought Harry price was faking
it right the hit that he was doing it
because like I said he was a magician
but they never come there to disprove
well
it was true now it should be noted that
a couple members of the SPR work with
their comrades on this and you know said
though they back to price up and they
think they did a good investigation
however the majority of the SPR at the
time he thought that he had faked it or
that he had embellished things to make
it a better that was the thing with the
Enfield haunting I mean Maurice grosse
was SPR and he said yeah it's here man
come check this out they didn't care
yeah they wouldn't even sell they
wouldn't send one of their own skeptics
yeah to go down there and observe it
yeah now which I should I water yeah if
I was just a skeptic I would have gone
to the and field house to go [ __ ] this
[ __ ] I'm gonna be there a couple days I
must show you there's nothing to this
you know that's what I would say that's
what I would have yeah but I've seen
poltergeist myself I know what would
have happened the phenomena would have
tapered off a little bit for about 12 6
to 12 hours and then it slowly would
have started ramping back up the skeptic
would have gone in denial I've seen it
before and then all of a sudden it gets
to the point where they can't deny it
they [ __ ] lose it and they want to
leave because they're coming
face-to-face with something that they
have convinced themselves could not
happen and when it stares them right in
the face
they're they kind of have an identity
crisis you know yeah we saw people see
it and go ah man I'm out of here
and it was sleet never saw him again but
yeah I think that was kind of you know I
don't know maybe the case here because I
don't really think the svr SP are really
investigated the house wallet was still
standing right now I'm not gonna
understand there's not much they can do
in that game rice case yeah I must have
talked about how they botched Enfield
yeah but you know those people are all
dead now yeah the SPR today is not gonna
be the same people well yeah pretty much
all done and I'm not gonna say while I
do think because the thing about Borle
rectory is that if you look at pretty
much any skeptical website even some non
skeptical websites even some paranormal
websites will tell you that a lot of the
stuff about poorly rectory is probably
exaggerated particularly a lot of the
stuff that Mary Ann came up with because
she later on said yeah I faked a bunch
of it well I'm gonna tell you just based
on based on you know what you said so
far about this case if that's a genuine
case it's just a minor
even if it's real I would say yeah
that's a little one that's the thing I
kind of feel like maybe there was maybe
there was paranormal activity going on
wasn't what the super impressive right
so maybe there was kind of an incentive
for what investigators went in there
when people went in there was like oh we
need to ramp this up a little bit right
yeah you know to make it seem more
exciting maybe and I feel like a lot of
the stuff like I said about the history
of the area with the nun and everything
like that they pretty much know that
that's not true that that's just the
local regions not to say that American
ghosts are superior to British but the
Bobby Mackey case is more impressive
than this one you know or the reports
came out of the body no like I said it's
kind of interesting to me that I didn't
even know that Borle Church was still
there and that there was actually a lot
of reported paranormal activity over
there mostly noises you know cold spots
footsteps you know hearing voices and
things like that so there's a lot of
that [ __ ] going on and they had like a
lot of interviews with people that had
seen various things they also talked
about a guy who had been working there
and saw the nun on four separate
occasions like and he didn't know that
it was he didn't know anything about the
phantom none evidently and he actually
thought it was a person like he said it
looked like a solid person so he didn't
really think anything of it the first
three times but then the fourth time he
was like well that's kind of weird so he
went up to talk to her and then she just
kind of vanished
RAAA then he was like oh [ __ ] that's a
ghost he didn't realize he thought it
was a person that's what he said anyway
but it's not grabbing people and trying
to shove their heads down and like I
said most of the poltergeists type stuff
didn't really start coming about until
Harry price got there and and then when
he voiced her family got there I was
talking about was throwing me out of bed
and when they left the poltergeist
activity left from the scene also pretty
much I was dependent on those people you
know while I was researching this and I
I found this really cool thing evidently
there's this guy and his name is Ashley
Thorpe I think his name is and he spent
the last six years making a movie about
Borle rectory and he it's funded
entirely through IndieGoGo Kickstarter
what have you and it was apparently
gonna start out as a short film but then
you know he got more backing and he got
some kind of big stars by the Julian
Sands as the narrator and stuff yes so
he ended up making it it's I think it's
a 75 minute movie and it premiered at I
can't remember what the film festival it
was there premiered last year 2017 you
said it looked awesome and I yeah and
I've seen clips of it and actually if
you're watching the YouTube video the
little bit that I put at the beginning
of this little clip of videos actually
from the trailer of that of that and
what he did was he filmed the actors in
front of a green screen and so the all
of the backgrounds all of the inside of
the house obviously and stuff like that
is all computer animated but then he
made it he filmed in a black and white
everybody that's in it has like very
period 20s the 30s Universal monster
movie type costuming Tech makeup and
it's just got this really cool like
flickering smoky black and white kind of
look to it it's really beautiful now
when these guys able to dig up any more
information about the case that wasn't
found anywhere else you know what I'm
not now they did get to go to the Harry
price archives and there's a library the
library that's in London they have the
archives there so evidently they dug
pretty deep because this is it's a
fictional on fictional film but he calls
it like a documentary docudrama
it's like a docudrama yeah so it's so
it's kind of like it's narrated but it's
a fictionalized account but the stuff
that happened in there is [ __ ] that I
really that was really happening and
actually I really kind of want to see
this movie because from seeing like
little clips of it said it looks really
really cool and I think it's really cool
that he spent all this time making it
she's nobody's a pretty young guy and
you know he spent six years working on
it and it really shows it looks really
gorgeous so so
it's an elusive case in da or may and
may have not happened if it's true it's
most likely just a very minor haunting I
would think that that's probably more of
what it is a versus a poltergeist case I
don't really buy the poltergeist reports
you know yeah thanks it does too elusive
it does seem like the most common
reports even back from the old days were
of apparitions mostly of a parishioner
and just like minor [ __ ] like footsteps
and what light was coming on and it's
more likely that if there you think
paranormals going on there that that's
what it is gonna be just apparitions
right and this holds these legendary
tales of nuns being walled up just very
unlikely and the thing about that too
that I forgot to mention is that the
reverend bulls family cuz remember he
had all those kids later on a lot of
them said a lot of the things that are
attributed to them in a lot of the Borla
rectory stories they said that [ __ ]
never happened
yeah people had into it yes they said
they people added [ __ ] it's like we
never said that there was a nun that was
bricked up they either said that we
didn't say that or that we just made
that up to make the house seem more
romantic or whatever so you know a lot
of the [ __ ] about that a lot of the
story about this place you know that
gets repeated some of it when you look
into it it's not it's not really German
right yeah so what do you think like you
said I think there might have been some
kind of minor shape there are maybe
people did see Aborigines but most
likely nothing happened I'm mostly maybe
it's my most likely nothing it's a good
story though I've always been fascinated
by Borla rectory and like I said
especially like the writing on the walls
and [ __ ] like that even though I think
that was probably part of this [ __ ] that
Marian faked to be open mind and I'm
gonna put it 75 25 75 percent chance
nothing happened 25 percent chance it
was just a minor haunting that had stuff
later Antioquia bunch of stuff later
yeah and maybe it didn't last that long
probably I kinda yeah yeah on that
alright we're getting to the end of the
show so we will wrap up this episode
about Borle rectory and various other
ghost stories remember if you like the
show to like share subscribe share
around to all your friends on all your
social media also be sure to check out
our azazel store
özil calm / 13 o'clock we have t-shirts
and a tote bag of all different designs
that you can check out if you want to
and also if you'd like to financially
support the show you can check out our
patreon at patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account also be sure to check out
our last movie review which was the
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]